Hello everybody, my name is  Markiplier
and welcome to the Try Not to Laugh Challenge.
Now as you know,
this challenge has been done many, many, many,
many, many
manymanymanymanymany
*Overlapping voices* Many many many many
SO MANY! Incredibly many!
People are desperate to laugh,
so these videeeOoOS...
So these videos come up, and then people do videos of people watching videos
... where they laugh.
Keep in mind: this is all for your safety.
The unbridled humor that's contained in these videos
is just too raw for you to process by yourself.
If you were to watch it
without the filter of me to absorb some of the laughter,
then- my god, y-y-your brain would just implode from all-
implode from all the laughter,
and THEN explode...
because that's how implosions work.
I'm starting out with
Reddit's Try Not to Laugh Challenge
because it's, by far,
the highest RATED video that I've seen.
There's a ton of videos that have a lot of views,
and not that this doesn't, it's got 11 million,
but
there's other videos out there that have a ton of views,
but not well liked.
Alright, whatever, my humor shields are at maximum.
Bring it on.
BLEEEHP
bLLLEEEEEHHHHHH
HBLLLEP
HHLLLLEEEEPPLB
(girl on right) Oh that's nice, what does it say?
(guy on left) CUuUuUuUuUUuUNT!
*wheezing from camera guy*
*cat shuffles slightly*
*continues shuffling*
*CLUNK*
I do parkour, *bleeped*!
(camera guy) What do you do?!!
I DO PARKOUR, *BLEEPED*!!
(camera guy) WHAT DO YOU DO?!!
I DO PARKOOOOOOOOUUR!!!!
(camera guy) GET IT
*man screaming*
*BAM* *SLAP*
(background laughter and clapping)
*suppressed laughter*
*surpressed laughter*
Ahh, didn't laugh.
Nope
That didn't get me
I had spastic convulsions in my chest,
but that's not laughter.
Oh this is gonna be harder than I thought...
There's a reason that this one is highly rated!
I can tell!
(newscaster) -playing football, blind.
(blind football player) Anything's possible.
*Blind Witness - All Alone playing*
WHAT THE FUCK IS GOING ON?!
*deathcore guitar riffs*
*man playing guitar poorly* (Possibly attempting to play Good Riddance by Green Day)
FUCK!!
*snickering, poorly suppressed laughter*
inside Mark's head: (Deathcore plays) WHAT THE FUCK IS GOING OOOONNNNNN??!!
*Bursts out laughing*
*laughter continues*
*Groans loudly*
PHEW *deep sniff*
Ahhhhh
I'm a giggly bitch by nature~ Markiplier 2016
Hoh...
(child) What the fuck is taking so long?
(lady behind camera) Remy, come!
(lady behind camera) Remy, sit!
(lady behind camera) Speak!
(dubbed in deep voice) Fuck!
(lady behind camera) Good boy!
*poorly surpressed laughter*
*SMACK*
(penguins) *Honk in despair*
(fallen penguin) HWWUAAHA
*Timmy trumpet" played on trombone*
"Timmy trumpet" played on trombone, oven clanging to rhythm*
I've seen that video before and I love it a lot.
When I first saw that, I laughed for like five minutes straight.
I LOVE that video.
(camera guy) Can you guys say Colorado!
(giraffe on skis) I'M A GIRAFFE!
(Whisper) Wait...
(camera guy) -Colorado!
(giraffe on skis) I'M A GIRAFFE!!
*suppressed laughter
(Newsman) -at the show..
(Newsman) Ap...
(Newsman) aaaAAAhhHHHHHHH
AAaAaHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
(Little girl) Go!
*CRASH*
(Little girl) BWAAAH!
*suppressed laughter
*breathing in*
*sniff*
*exhale*
You can't...
You can't double-whammy
with something I haven't seen
and then go "bWaAAH
MMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
(Newscaster) -a few minutes later, the bear was spotted behind this home in Moreland Hills
(Newscaster) This recreation identifies how witnesses say how the bear escaped into the woods.
*man walks on grass*
*scrumpf*
*camera man wheezes in background*
*unintelligible noises from class*
*remix of the child hitting his head to the tune of Mario*
*loud distorted thud*
*gunshot and metallic clattering*
This is why Mom doesn't FUCKING love you!
*Snickering*
*Mark's confused*
(guy offscreen, casually) Hey Ron.
(guy on ground, casually) Hey Billy.
*Manic laughter*
*sniff*
*laughter continues*
*less intense laughter*
Okay, I've lost.. probably many times now, but I'm gonna keep going.
Because I owe it to myself.
(offscreen guy) Hey Ron.
(guy on ground) Hey Billy.
(guy on ground) ...that hurt.
*wild giggling*
Oh my god, *in between giggles* I love that one.
(newsman) -at the show..
(Newsman) ap...
HAAAAAHH
AAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHH
*giggles*
(little girl) Go!
(little girl) BWAAAH!
*giggling*
Oh my god, and *giggles* of course
it was a classic!
Not this one, fuck this one!
*man screams*
*BAM*
*mark laughing*
(newscaster) -playing football, blind.
*Mark giggles* It's just the way he hits it!
*laughing* and this one!
(Blind Witness - All Alone playing again)
WHAT THE FUCK IS GOING OOOOOONNNNNNN??!!
*laughing*
*laughter*
(guy in video) FUCK!!
This-this- *laugther*
*more laughing* The sequence is so good!
Like, I know it's bad, because
*giggling* it's a blind kid trying to play football, and then what happened-
* laughter* Oh my god, funny, is funny!
(blind kid) Anything's possible.
WHAT THE FUCK IS GOING OOOOOONNNNNNN??!!
Oh jeez, I'm a bad person!
Like I'm sorry, it's funny!! *giggles*
Yeah, I-I-I honestly didn't think I was gonna get got
uhhh...
that early, but,
man, that was actually legitimately a good one.
You know what I do like, though?
I- there's one video that- there's videos that I found recently
I uh, it's uh, it's uh, music...
...videos without music.
*dog barks*
*dissonant strumming*
(mark) Oh...
(man) Hm?
*an acoustic song begins, badly*
*chewing sound*
*acoustic guitar playing and squeaking shoes*
*acoustic guitar, mouth chewing sounds and playing and squeaking shoes*
*shoes squeak*
"Hoo!" *shoe taps*
"Eheeheeheehee!" *shoes keep squeaking and the guitar*
"HOOOOOO" *hiccups*
*guitar continues*
*groan* Alright, that did not go very well for me
Unfortunately,
or expectedly,
I failed the challenge, I'm sorry.
I've got too much joy inside my soul and I laugh very easily.
But I've got a funny feeling that you guys at home also failed,
so let me know if you did, let me know if you didn't,
and if you have other funny videos,
there's tons and tons of funny videos available on the internet,
all across the internet for everybody to see,
so if you got more,
that you want ME
to "not laugh at,"
let me know in the comments below, and thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you in the next video.
BUHBYEEE!